ich begebe mich auf den rückweg
hast du alles stoppt oder sowie lange
währt schon aufnehmen aber wenn wir
nachher so lange auf dem kann man da
schon in die planung
okay wir wollen wir schon jetzt sagen
dass eine folge 13 12 minuten dann geht
es genug denn die täglich kommen dann
sitzt man keiner beschwert 13 minuten
vor sorin jetzt 36 zahl freitag der
dreizehnte und so setzt genau 13 minuten
höhe sollte jetzt genau nach 13 minuten
nach 13 minuten nebst bisschen kürzer
machen
12 oder keine anleihen ihm so lange auf
bisschen fest sagt man hat doch genau 13
minuten und des übels nach 1
verabschieden dann wird's ein bisschen
zu knapp dann machen wir 10 läuft der
sonst zwölf minuten das war kamera hast
du für die fans kenne mich nur so eine
summe samsung dinge ins camp aber für
meine richtigen videos habe ich immer
die canon eos 650 de bis 26
ich habe eine 600d auch mit 66 50 leser
die neue habe ich noch gar nicht
die kaufen.de ist unnötig wenn man die
600d und da ist es wirklich unnötig sich
zum update wird dunkel komm ins bett ja
danke das ist mir jetzt sagst bin schon
seit fünf minuten auf dem rückweg hier
okay das wieder vergessen zu sagen nee
ich hab jetzt gesagt dass es dunkel ist
ja du sollst mir vorher bescheid sagen
genommen weg zurück nach hause
ich werde jetzt auch ein link setzen bei
rüdiger schädlich habe gar kein bett
mail beim haus in meinem kleinen haus
ich habe alles auf meinem werk versetzt
und konnte sich später ganz einfach sein
rüdiger penn soll ich noch mal nach der
ruhiger schlafen er da mache ich da eben
noch ein big point war gordon gekko ist
auch schon so eine fackel drin sondern
locker schon sehen echte nicht mehr
irgendwie ein bisschen einsam oder also
ich meine ich habe ja rüdiger und was
habt ihr so gemacht
natürlich ist ausgeschlossen helmut hey
von angeboten
so war es bei mir ab ins bett
aber es fällt mit ihrer arbeit auch hier
bitte komm ich bin im bett so brauche
ich nichts sehen ja dass man so viel an
mir ich gehe auf gute nacht geschlafen
so ich werde mich jetzt mal das haus
setzen ich hab jetzt anderthalb stacks
eichenholz müll stört obwohl ich auch
dies andere holzarten sie da reinging
jetzt mal die andere seite da hinten hin
vielleicht sind daher noch andere sachen
andere holzarten gebt eure vielleicht
verstehen zombie brain
zombie brains am morgen sorgen
so ist das meine festplatte c sagt die
ganze zeit wenig speicherplatz der
freisprecher topsystem c ist gering
klicken sie am samstag der erste kurze
zeit
nein das ist eigentlich relativ egal ist
der relativ früh sag ich mir du hast
noch genug zeit für locker eine halbe
stunde
aber da wir ja noch nicht auf meiner
festplatte auf alexandra terabyte
festplatte für aufnahmen dass dies noch
die ist noch sehr frei jahr drei
terabyte können wir noch eine stunde
aufnehmen noch viel mehr als eine stunde
ich habe schon battle staffeln gemacht
wir haben dreieinhalb stunden am stück
begann sind die banken die sind gegangen
wenn die gehen rainer stunden am stück
so wärme ist super ich weiß 333 habe
kann man kaum voll machen also mit halte
sich in einer woche doch schon weiß
manchmal nicht weiß was du meinst ich
weiß nicht ob ihm doch das andere ist
doch irgendwie schön an dem ich das
andere für die ich das machen ab jetzt
mittlerweile einplanen das ist immer so
wünsche ich mir dass ein plan jetzt vom
leben so meine kameraden minuten
das heißt ich werde jetzt noch mal
diesen stress wir haben ja schon wer
jetzt noch ein bisschen diese media auch
diese filme angucken weil ich ja nicht
mal was sinnvolles zu machen sind oben
habe ich schon was schönes auf die beine
stellt das wird ein richtig schönes
penthouse ist doch nicht mal die tür
drin aber ich habe noch nicht mal mit
meinem haus angefangen ich habe schon
alle rohstoffe die ich dafür benötige
das heißt in der nächsten folge dann
wiederum werde ich so was von produktiv
sein
der nächste aufnahmestation der nächsten
aufnahmesession ja aber für die
zuschauer auch in der nächsten folge
äußerlich vielleicht ist die folge jetzt
gerade zu ende
so packen jetzt noch so fünf minuten
folge oder wie nein das ist jetzt die
letzte folgt glaube ich wir werden dort
schon irgendwie wochen mit dem schnellen
kann aber sein dass er beim um gespielt
ein paar minuten länger sind als bei mir
oder so wir sprechen also jetzt nicht
genau aufs wort ab oder so gestellt und
den stellen wo es auch ein bisschen
passend ist also wenn ich gucke 13
minuten aber wenn ich jetzt gerade das
bettgestell ist da halt in 14 minuten zu
dürfen schweiz bestens
ich mag diese biomasse maxis eine
wasserkarte ab oder braucht
was
so ein blitz augen erschießt
ich würde gern mal seine sonne datenbank
für die ganzen erfahrungen ist monster
hier diesen in diesen dungeon was du
darauf gelegt hast das monster drin ist
und blitz auges schießt einer
mein gott aber du willst du nicht die
sachen den kisten wir gehen dabei der
zuerst zusammen rein geht alles wenn du
dir alles wollte ich habe entdeckt dass
zwar war ich will dich töten sofort den
westflügel grad ich habe aus dem verkehr
was ist das gibt so viele schöne berge
habe ich den richtigen weg ausgesucht
ich glaube muss dein weg für immer und
ewig treu bleiben
es gibt ein paar umzüge diesem in diesem
wer weil dieses jetzt alles so lerne ich
habe einfach eine riesige fläche
geschaffen wo schaut in unserem nahe
gelegenen gebiet also ich glaub ich mal
langsam zu dir
ich muss mich ein bisschen gucken hier
das auch nicht erfülle
es gibt zu viele höhlen hier oder
konflikt heraus ich gucke reinkommt
da ist seine höhle
ja ich bin in seine höhle einfach
eingesprungen also mit voller mit voller
motivation reingekommen so weit wollte
es mal ganz kurz überlegen wie ich das
bauer
da kommt ein block hinter kommt eines
mit 21 23 567 dann acht neun zehn elf
zwölf dreizehn blöcke lang wird mein
haus hat hayes gesprochen hatte jetzt
bitte mal gar nicht reden
13 das heißt wenn ich das haus
theoretisch theorie stuhl auch hier
anfangen würde müsste ich so 23 hier
hakt dann wiederum ja das passt so dann
wieder ein 23 zack dann hier noch mal
das passt mir wird die 2 das ist aber
falsch lächeln und winken männer lächeln
und winken so weiter nehme ich das nur
kurz um das coni machen sein denn ich
mache mir dann passt das ja so viel
geschafft
es gab es spontane idee die ich hier
gerade hatte die ich hier gerade
versuche umzusetzen
ich hoffe ich renne die richtige
richtung welches verlauf mappus und
muslime waypoint setzen
ja ok passt alles was sie bauen will
ich habe es sogar hügelgrab gefunden
dass unsere city weg city rollers mit
zehn jahren gehörte gefühlt kommt er mit
jetzt angeschlossen
ich bin voll der hipster ist dass vor
dem 50 jahren dabei ist okay ich weiß
von butterfly butterfly oder wussten
davon oder baut der conti was schönes
ach nee wat ne schöne auch warten schöne
was das schon schön aussieht was ist
denn jetzt jemand kommt ist einfach ab
durch diese person töten egal wer es ist
spaß
es ist schwer das haus für man selbst
spannend ich per hacke war gespannt was
daraus wird
bis jetzt mal langsam zu ende kommen zur
aufnahme muss schauen wie ich das mache
ja ja okay da deine kamera platz uns
vorgeht will ich sagen danke fürs
zuschauen wir haben jetzt eine station
gemacht von vorne angefangen
19 40 oder von 18 24 uhr
das sind zwei stunden 20 minuten das
sind menge was wünschen aufgenommen
haben das heißt wir konnten bisher nicht
eure ganzen kommentare verfolgen
allerdings würde ich sagen das macht
eigentlich gar nichts das heißt wir
gucken uns das jetzt einfach an wir
konnten bisher nicht auf euch hören aber
soll sie haben auch innerlich sinnvolles
gemacht also also von bisher noch nicht
so schlimm
ihr könnt uns weiterhin tipps themen et
cetera in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr euch sehr sehr verbunden 234
und links auf jeden fall bis zur
nächsten folge und werden nicht
vergessen kommentieren habe ich schon
alles gesagt
und ja auch wieder in der ak